في ايران ايضا وتحت نوع من القمع يشبه
الاحتلال العسكري تعيش محافظه بلوشستان في
ايران احد اكبر مراكز الاحتجاجات في
البلاد في الوقت الراهن وفق مركز حقوق
الانسان في ايران هنا في زاهدان عاصمه
محافظه بلوتشستان كما نشاهد لم تهدا فيها
التظاهرات منذ اربعه اشهر رغم القمع
والترهيب المتعدد الاشكال الذي تمارسه
السلطات الايرانيه منذ فتره الاعتقالات
الجامعيه سما اساسيه في حمله الحكومه
القمعيه حيث قدرت وكاله انباء نشطاء حقوق
الانسان اعتقال نحو 20 الف شخص في جميع
انحاء البلاد منذ بدء الاضطرابات اما في
زهدان فتم اعتقال ملايا يقل عن
185 شخصا ومن المحتمل ان يكون العدد
الفعلي للمعتقلين اعلى بكثير بسبب طبعا
انقطاع الانترنت وتهديدات الاجهزه الامنيه
للعائلات هناك ولكن الامر لم يرهب سكان
زاهدا لبل كان له تاثير معاكس واصر على
الاستمرار بالمطالبه بحقوقهم واسقاط
النظام الايراني مركز حقوق الانسان في
ايران كشف ايضا ان المتظاهرين يتعرضون
لاصابات يفضلون الذهاب ولا يفضلون طبعا
الذهاب الى المستشفيات حتى لو اصابتهم
رصاصه كي يتجنبوا الاعتقال من قبل قوات
النظام
[موسيقى]